smart speakers your GPS and robot
vacuums were just the start artificial
intelligence is growing at warp speed
and Sam Altman who operates the surging
chat GPT compared AI to the invention of
the printing press at a U.S Senate
hearing Tuesday but the promise of
innovation comes with a warning I think
if this technology goes wrong it can go
quite wrong Congress is concerned it
risks waiting too long to pass laws that
will govern AI after failing years ago
to set rules for social media we should
be concerned for our privacy we expect
to be concerned for our Liberty and that
we should be concerned for our control
over our lives so let's make sure that
the tools actually work for us and we
don't end up working for the tools even
the industry is pushing for safety
standards we think that regulatory
intervention by governments will be
critical to mitigate the risks of
increasingly powerful models